[Musique]
moi j'adore le cinéma quand j'avais 10
ans j'entrais dans un cinéma je les voir
ce film les 400 coups de françois
truffaut je crois que c'était un film
érotique
parce que le petit blues for a le blues
la traduction de 400 coups ça faisait
penser au blowjobs au pipe
alors on a fait quatre des kilomètres
sous la neige pour les voir ce film il
ya que mon frère et moi qui avons vu ce
film parce que tout le monde était déçu
parce qu'un film en noir et blanc avec
les sous titres pas une seule fille
enfin toujours est il que huit de mes
copains ont quitté le cinéma en cours en
osant allez vous faire voir les pubs et
moi on est resté et on est tombé
amoureux du cinéma français ce jour-là à
l'âge de 10 ans avec le film de truffaut
reset une leçon d'amour dépoussiérer
[Musique]